tonight we have some more information
released about the memorial service for
senator harry reid this saturday so
among those attending will be president
biden and some of the senators favorite
artists christian casadas joining us now
live from the smith center in downtown
las vegas where the service will take
place this weekend christian
well denise bryant as you mentioned in
addition to family and close friends the
memorial service will include president
joe biden previous presidents and even
musical acts all expected to attend now
again this all taking place inside the
smith center this saturday and the
service starts at 11 o'clock and it's
only for invited guests only now keep in
mind it could also affect your commute
as many roads could be shut down
senator reid will be remembered in las
vegas on saturday he passed away
december 28th tributes continue to pour
in this one from nevada senator jackie
rosen to me
and to so many nevadans he was also a
source of inspiration and pride the
memorial for invited guests include
remarks from president joe biden nancy
pelosi and chuck schumer the eulogy
delivered by former president barack
obama just a glimpse of those he was
close with like senator catherine cortez
masto she grew up down the street from
the family and supported her in public
service he would not back down from a
fight
especially when it involved nevada elder
russell ballard acting president of the
quran of the 12 apostles for the church
of jesus christ of latter-day saints
will deliver a message on behalf of the
family and the church the late senator
belonged to for over 60 years security
will be tight around the venue not only
police but secret service the program
will be live streamed which will include
reed's favorite artists carol king and
brandon flowers of the killers a special
tribute to honor reed's legacy before
his body is flown to washington and i
want to honor senator reid for his
lifetime of fighting the good fight for
our state he helped make nevada what it
is today a world-class destination
now back out here live you can expect
heavy police presence around the smith
center and road closures in the vicinity
of the 15 from spring mountain to the
spaghetti bowl saturday morning also
temporary road closures expected friday
night between six and nine o'clock and
that is for the arrival of air force one
and the departure now we have a full
list of all the road closures right now
available on our website
eightnewsnow.com christian gossett is
live local now